the battle for Pacheco is over or at
least that's what Kurdish fighters been
doing they control it shattered
thoroughfares and its neighborhoods seem
quieter enough although nobody's
absolutely sure 100 or so is militants
tried to hold this town their body still
litter the streets but there may be
others in hiding waiting to kill for
their fanatical cause we were taken by
Peshmerga soldiers to a middle-class
neighborhood being re-engineered by
Islamic state kitchens and bedrooms
hallways and cupboards everything had
been adapted for combat this spot was a
makeshift armory although some rooms
were full of dirt we soon discovered why
the militants had built themselves a
tunnel a way to cross the street without
being seen by coalition aircraft above
it's very deep and it's dark as well the
walls very soft but this narrow track
propped up by a few beams was more than
just an underground passage well this is
extraordinary it looks like they built
themselves sleeping quarters down here
in a bookcase they left a stack of
papers there were Russian recruits
trying to write in Arabic and in order
to squash intimate feelings for young
boys this is fascinating we've found
this tiny notebook down here and in it
it lists the type of weapons that the
militants had on this page it says that
this area is Islamic States position 100
there 100 the defensive position and
here they've listed the names of
Fighters individual fighters and their
commanders who I presume we're living
here in this complex my pesh MERGA guide
told me they'd wiped them all out a few
days ago honey bunny Josh neer back on
the surface we found the collection of
is rockets outside the offices to the
local transport firm they were brought
here by the Kurds who've made this spot
their temporary HQ but the general in
charge told me he's more worried about
militants in hiding period by only I
need dunya by Oni shows I can see honest
not recognized the Peshmerga this one
the no burden under each page has
frantic aandava they away began a
thought rockin minute honorable imposed
a shoulder Cascione datacom mm - mirela
katakana I'm gonna buy Eurovision we
watched a team of engineers inch their
way towards a church called st. George's
they scoured the earth and the ceilings
for bombs and booby traps and the signs
of is activity were all around like
these half-finished suicide belts while
engineers search for explosives the
church director surveyed the scene and
he was shocked like the rest of the
town's residents he was evacuated two
years ago this his first date
Joseph LeMay was off ranch houses
sanomat wound of William a to an army
but the Hawea nakawara chromophore need
lobbying budget battle in Alma
California see yet the worst is yet to
come
pass the burning oil in the west lies
the city of Mosul with a million or more
civilians inside and it will take months
and months to hold it John sparks Sky
News in northern Iraq